the kind introduction
I flew in from New York last night and
I'm very excited to be here at Stanford
with you guys so I'd like to talk about
two things while I'm here with the first
did is my entrepreneurial journey and
share some of the lessons I've learned
and the second is talk about the power
and the potential for creativity I'm a
topic that typically isn't discussed and
we certainly mentioned but I really do
believe it's a source of them and it's
an unlimited resource that people really
should take more advantage of so I'll
start with how I came to this country as
you can tell from accidents I'm an
American oh that's I wasn't born in
America I came here when I was 16 years
old with my parents he's a professor so
we kind of jumped around from university
to university and I graduated with the
finance and accounting degree and I did
what most people with finance accounting
degrees is like I went to Wall Street so
I did M&A my first year and I found it
fascinating just to be in the midst of
so much you know just to seek a really
global capital flows learns lots of
skills financial skills etc I spent way
too much time with models and I'm
talking about financial models by the
way so so so that's I definitely learned
a lot in that department but I think I
felt something was missing and we would
go to pitch companies around helping
them raise capital at JPMorgan and I
just had this burning urge to be on the
other side of the table so I said I
called my mom and I told her that I
wanted to be an entrepreneur and like a
typical African mother she's like well
what's you know that that's not a job
you know what's what's an entrepreneur
and it's like I have to have a real
company to work on a real business
opportunity to go after so I figured
that the best way today is to have so
transition
points for myself and for that for me
and that was Business School so while I
was at Harvard Business School I didn't
have one interview for a job because I
was it was clear in my mind that I
wanted to be an entrepreneur I wanted to
have full control over my life I wanted
to have the freedom to choose how I
spent every single day of my life going
forward and so that's that was a
decision I made so after graduating from
school I ended up starting a company
called a free deck with a classmate of
mine and my brother and so you have to
think back in 2000 when I graduated
right so internet penetration in Africa
was still pretty low but among the
corporations and the corporates it was
pretty it was it was good enough and the
idea behind a free deck which is a play
on Nasdaq is to create a platform to
trade financial assets money markets and
foreign exchange and securities in
Africa given just the the noun the
penetration of internet access on the
continent and we raised of friends and
family around we flew through SAP flew
to South Africa to now enjoy working on
business development deals and the
company failed and that leads me to the
very first lesson right so people often
talk about make sure pick an opportunity
that you feel like you're the best
person to solve and it certainly greats
sound advice but remember that you can
have a kind of conflict of interest
right so not only are you the person
deciding who's the best person to build
this company the person is also you so
our mistake was so we look at our team
right so I had to finance background my
my co-founder had operations background
my brother was a securities lawyer and
on paper it made sense that we would be
almost like the perfect team to go solve
this problem in Africa but in reality
what we found was that we didn't really
understand the nature of the problem and
while it made sense on paper that
foreign foreign financial assets should
be you know you know you can create
great platform to trade and financial
assets we didn't understand the kinds of
agency issues we found particularly in
Nigeria so what we found that while it
made sense to auction your phoronix for
your foreign reserve efficiently and
transparently as a kind of a general
market principle the members the CFO's
the treasurer's of these organizations
had their own so side deals with we know
the buyers and sellers of these
securities so we certainly didn't create
the kind of liquidity and and adoption
we expected so there I was kind of you
know essentially broke after you know
however is you know have it loans and I
had to get a job I had to get back and
pay the rent so I knew I didn't want to
do Investment Banking again I wanted
something more intellectually engaging
so I decided well I'm gonna go work for
a hedge fund
so the first so was a was a it was a
financial derivatives have hedge fund
focus on convertible bonds and credit
default swaps but that's why I learned
what I think is probably the most
valuable lesson so far which is that
ideas matter and I and I think everyone
else should take ideas very seriously
and put in the financial world you could
create a financial trade you can you can
suggest a trade idea can Nets millions
in in a couple of in our days right and
when you think of yourselves as
entrepreneurs who are creating companies
you almost feel like well ideas are good
but I need to in a higher team find an
MVP raise capital etc I would like to
argue that those are literally
inefficiencies their aunts virtues you
know in and of themselves and that the
true source of human capital and
potential is an ideas you come up with
so after three years at a hedge fund I
decided to leave and give another give
the entrepreneurial journey another shot
and so I started to come they called hop
stop
so the idea around Hopstop was
essentially this right so you have what
the site essentially does it lets you
get door-to-door directions using in a
walk-in walking directions subways buses
etc so you'll enter and start an address
the answer your ending address and it
would give you walking directions the
trains get tell you where to get off
where to take the next bus and from the
bus and of the bus stop I had to get to
your final destination so for those of
you those of you who use Google transits
and we actually started and own that
space before they and they join those
two years after so that was the company
but I'd love to share with you at least
the initial stories as you know the
initial kind of hops top stories early
on so I lived in Brooklyn at that time
and I remember having to go on a date
under the Lower East Side and I think it
was somewhere in Eldridge streets and
then you know you had the subway map so
obviously we didn't have you know the
kind of everyone the map and everyone's
phone and I remember figuring out well
how actually do I get to 200 Eldridge
Street and I'm in Sudbury and I have a
horrible sense of direction and I got
lost
etc and I don't quite remember how the
dates went but I have vivid memories of
what I did next very next morning I'm I
went to the subway station
I grabbed the subway map put in my the
flow of the apartments in in Brooklyn
and I used the only tool I could use
which is Excel because as a finance guy
so so what I wanted to do was like how
do I describe the subway system to a
computer science engineer and so such
that so that they'll be able to write an
algorithm to solve that problem so you
know and I had some experience with kind
of datasets etc so that's why I started
right so I I built I built spreadsheets
okay well have a roots and stops and
exits and it so all have the core kind
of informational information model for
for the company so I went to Elance
which is a nickname called up markets
and I found it
upper in Russia to build it so we
continued on this process you know
iteration after iteration until we
actually had a viable product and called
it an MVP and these days and the
interesting thing about that story is
that actually never met I met a
developer Alex for the first time four
years after we start working so for the
for the vast majority of my time at the
company we worked remotely using you
know I think then it was a messenger etc
and I definitely had a few lessons from
from that experience the first one is
that product matters right product
solves so many problems in so many ways
right so it helps you retain and grow
your user base it helps you get PR right
because unless someone in the press
reuses it you know the one rights of a
product that they aren't actually in
love with it helps with the viral growth
of your business obviously with a with
existence of the social graph there are
much more efficient ways to engineer the
kind of virality you want in a consumer
facing and products but back then it was
really in a press and kind of really
old-fashioned kind of word of mouth so
that was like the early days and I was
obsessed about the product I know so my
wife would look at me and wonder well
stare at the screen and hops oh by the
way was only three pages right so you
enter your home page enter your
directions and you get the results right
there isn't that much to to think about
but there there is right there's so many
elements of that experience that I
absolutely obsessed about and I think
one of the reasons we continue to grow
even after Google stay competing with us
was because we have such a loyal user
base I'm going forward so again products
matters products and solve so many
problems going forward
so while I was at while I was at Hopstop
Columbia Business School students and
emailed me and said you know he wanted
to he loved hop stopping when it should
be an entrepreneur but he didn't have a
company he didn't have ideas or you know
that he he could work on I said well I
have tons of ideas that's me for coffee
and discussed a few so I pitched him on
an idea which was based on my own
frustration I've been able to find a
travel specialist so so back then if you
wanted to travel to - if you wanted to
do a safari in South Africa for example
but it's easy to get a flight in a hotel
because you can use Expedia in his kayak
I can use Travelocity etc but if you
want if you wanted what back then people
called long till travel right so this
kind of like more specialized travel
experiences whether you want to do a
safari you want to do some wine tasting
and in Kenya for example and it's hard
to find an online solution to that
problem and the business the business
was essentially aggregating demands or
interest for these kinds of travel and
then monetize in that interest through a
network of travel professionals were
willing to pay you for that lead so kind
of lead gen meets travel was an
essential concept so it was great so I
was a Muslim I was more focused on the
product and he was more focused on
business development and sales so we
eventually raised the venture capital
for the business we hire the CEO to
continue running the company and the
company ISM is still exists and it's not
won by USA Today but so and I did this
while I was a CEO of Hopstop but I also
realized that my true passion and I
should my true interest and my my core
strength is really in the kind of early
stages of a company so I approached my
board and with their supports I ended up
we ended up recruiting a new CEO for the
company then the company was in I think
20 cities or so and and he did a
fantastic job the new CEO and scaled is
I think too close to 300 cities
I think about some of the acquisition so
it was a decision that that was a really
tough decision to make just because I
was so product centric and to be baby
with a hand over a company that you've
built you know cannot really from
scratch to someone else to you know to
have stewardship over it's a pretty
tough thing for any entrepreneur to do I
thought it was the right thing to do
just given my own particular skillset
and and that's kind of understanding of
what my own particular passions were am
I am i a deficient system particularly
in terms of growth and skill in the
business so I then moved to to West
Africa where I essentially did private
equity for three years so then so I
switched from entrepreneur to noun
investing or wanting to invest in food
businesses started by you know small and
medium skill entrepreneurs so the whole
idea was you know if we could if I could
invest capital and also help in in
addressing the food challenges in West
Africa it would be something worth doing
and I thought that at least I'll be able
to do good while making money as well so
we we saw lots of companies we looked so
one particular store was a soy
processing Factory in Kumasi which is an
hour away from Accra Ghana's capital and
so I walk into the guys were Factory
right and you see this kind of old
equipments and still rusted you see
holes in the wall and essentially this
entrepreneur had incredible vision in
terms of what he wanted to do but he
lacks lots of information he didn't have
really a templates begin to begin to
build his business he bought the wrong
fact an equipment from from from China
he just made so many fundamental he
didn't he didn't he didn't think about
the layouts or the factory to allow for
the optimal processing of soy etc and I
saw many companies like that right and
so I did a short TEDx talk on this whole
idea of a bit
in a box where if society is real goal
is to foster entrepreneurship especially
among small and medium-sized businesses
that account for the vast majority
reason around 50% of the non-government
a workforce we need to we can easily do
so much more to encourage it and kind of
the risk that that process for them so
the whole idea around the startup in the
box was basically say look let's think
of the verticals or the industries that
make sense whether soy processing mango
processing food processing silos
whatever it is you know and let's
creates and I crowdsource and open
source and make it freely available the
core elements of successful business of
that kind so think of being able to look
at say mango processing and be able to
say like here's a blueprints here's
here's an architect's submits a layout
of an you know an optimal factory for
for mango processing and then the
engineer says look for the process
engineer says look here's the best way
to set up your your lines be able to you
know get the results you want so
financial person contributes a simple
financial worksheet that let's let them
plan for working capital which was a
major issue in here the companies I saw
so that was that was that was the idea
and so for those for those of for those
of you interested you can just and
google my name and I think on YouTube
it's on YouTube if you are interested in
pursuing that but that was kind of what
I thought was missing on the African
continent so so we ended up not
investing in the food business as I
wanted and we did make some other
investments that also turned out ok but
I certainly didn't I was I didn't
succeed in the ability of being able to
contribute to the kind of food value
chain in West Africa so then in 2013
Apple bought Hopstop so I moved back in
2013 to to New York City and so there I
think is another lesson so so just think
of I think it was 2005 that Google
Transit launched right so
upwork 2007 probably so so there we were
small team of guys and girls in New York
City and literally the number one
competitor you have is Google I mean
that's you know that's a that's a pretty
tough place to be and you never know you
know people talk about the ups and downs
of entrepreneurship it's very true and
but the thing to realize that the ups
may actually be you know downs and downs
may actually be ups right so regardless
of what the good news or bad news you
have just keep on focus focusing on what
you need to do so to illustrate that so
one would argue that the the entry of
Google into you know our space was you
know one of the worst things to happen
and we continue to grow even though we
probably didn't grow as fast if you just
think about how how widely distributed
and syndicated the Google Maps product
is but I suspect I'm not I wasn't in the
board room when the Apple decision was
made but I suspect that the Apple
acquisition for of Hopstop was because
they had a competitive hole in their map
in the core mapping product and they
need they need to feel fill that hole so
again you know take take your good news
and take your bad news and just keep on
going because again for in my own case
the entry of you know Google was
probably one of the catalysts and for
apples acquisition of Hopstop so so over
the past 12 months have actually been
one of the most creative months for me
I can I can describe how I feel right
now because every elements of every
every month every couple of weeks an
idea pops into my head and I think the
good ideas and I'm very excited to work
on them and but what I see and to Tom's
introduction is what I see is well you
have these what you think of great ideas
then why can't they be great companies
right then as I observed
the you know what's happening in the in
the kind of incubator and accelerator
accelerator space I just feel like this
more they can be done and in some ways
the the the entrepreneurial process even
the United States reminds me of what I
experienced with coffee in Ghana is that
so you have you have ideas you have
passionate people who want to build and
great companies but you also lack so
much information so many resources to
execute on those ideas right and in my
mind I realized that I think that the
whole system can be really tected in a
much more efficient way so that the
countless entrepreneurs don't spend
their life savings and and and have all
the family issues that go with the
failures that are very often the case
with that many of these startup ideas so
my particular passion right now is
basically rethink the entrepreneurial
process we think how do good ideas turn
into great companies and create the
kinds of win wins right where you have
great idea
great company you have investors who
make enough money for the ideas and you
have the entrepreneurs who don't spend
you know 5 10 years of the of their
lives when the company that doesn't
result in the kind of outcomes they want
so so I had I came across a very
interested in commencement speech by a
guy named David Foster I'm not sure how
many of you who's who knows about David
Foster and ok great
so um it goes something like this so so
two little fish are swimming down a
stream and they come they come across
with this older big fish and all the big
fish says good morning boys how's the
water right and they swim by and one of
the little fish looks the other little
fish and says what the heck is water
it's I guess you guys so I thought was I
thought was very profound because it
really cuts at at the heart of the other
of the question of creativity so I
believe that in this very moment right
we're all right
immersed in unlimited potential you know
at this very moment you have the cusp of
the next big idea right and you might
wonder well um well you know I'm looking
for the next big idea but you know I'm
really struggling right and I think
that's the I believe that's the wrong
approach right so the key in my mind
it's a unleashing the kind of potential
human creativity that I think all of us
have is try not to look for the next big
idea right
what so instead of doing that I suggest
and I hope that you figure it out what
kinds of activities and habits do unity
inculcates right to be able to basically
be able to see the water next to you
right this is a different approach
because what you'll find is that not
only will you see that we choose sorts
you might see that which you didn't even
know what to look for but it's a whole
different set of possibilities that
become available to you once you have
that mental approach and towards
creativity and that the the idea oh
sorry
so to make it the prettiest of practical
terms right so well so what's the big
deal about creativity right you know
like you know we're you know you're
Stanford it's all about products all
about customers etc but I do believe
that creativity plays a big role in in
success right so I mean I I use uber to
get here and I'm sure there's a kind of
like the guys that came after uber and
the guys that came after them as well
but you know I use uber and that's what
I use so there are real competitive
Edge's in being first to market and if
you have a new idea that no one's
thought of right you own that space you
own the market share you own the you
quit thought leadership in the space and
it's a real competitive advantage
especially to the extent that you're
building network effect type businesses
it's a strong and it's a you know bid to
be first in doing something is a real
advantage even after starting a company
to be able to take comments ideas from
your customers from other people from
other industries and apply to your own
company again it's a source of you know
incredible value and and I encourage you
to think about as think of creativity as
a way of really only unleashing a lot of
value that's right there in front of you
right so you might not see it but it's
there so instead of looking for I trying
to figure out what stops you from seeing
really what's next to you
so so again that leads me to kind of
what I'm working on now so so because I
have gone through this period of lots of
creativity my challenge right now is to
figure away well how do I turn that
creativity and the ideas I have none
into companies so I'm working on a
variety of things but the first thing
that I realized that the number one
bottleneck for me is finding talented
people to to join the team and work on
these different ideas so far you know I
believe I believe creativity again as I
said it's also unlimited wealth you will
never run out of good ideas to start it
just haven't found those good ideas and
once you find the next one there'll be a
knock next one after that
it never ends there won't be a point in
human history where we would have all
the ideas all the services and all the
products we want we want right that'll
never happen those ideas are out there
you just need to figure out how to
actually see the water next to you it's
put it in more concrete terms
imagine a marketplace where you have the
small fish right competing with the
older big fish
and they don't even know this water next
to you so those are those are my
comments and those are my experiences so
far and I'd love to answer any questions
that you had what do you mean what's
what was your what's your most favorite
experience when you're here so question
was was my my most favorite experience
in private equity I wish if I can answer
that because for me it wasn't my thing I
realized again that I wanted to be an
entrepreneur so I certainly enjoyed my
time and you know in Ghana and Niger and
looking at looking at what but I wanted
to be entrepreneur right and that's and
and and the Apple still happened so that
gave me the luxury to go back and pursue
that but my true passion is creating
companies you know so people think of
businesses and entrepreneurs as business
guys but for me I really think of it as
arts right I think of businesses as a
form of creative expression where there
are their thins their unique experiences
that each of each one of us have and if
you have the intention or you have the
interest in in manifesting some of those
interests right for me that's a big part
of what drives me to create companies
you mentioned that with yourself in
situations where you're able to see
opportunities and I think different how
to generate ideas can you give maybe one
or two specific examples of what you did
differently or habits you actually
inculcated in your personal life that
sparked ideas that you didn't have
before
sure so one of the things I did over the
past twelve months is literally devote
an entire day to its invested in my
creativity so I would literally say
Fridays I wouldn't work I wouldn't have
any meetings set up and I think it's
it's everyone is different some sir some
people focus on kind of meditation so
people focus on listening to music
people focus on traveling and you know
experiencing new things but it's you
kind of neat that because while
education and society are great they're
very bad ads inculcating you know the
human spirits right in terms of what you
want to do right so we've traded kind of
an Auton s around of the world with kind
of potential right so you ought to do
this you should do this and I think
what's missing is the right the right
variety of human potential and I think
education has to play a role of
parenting has to pay a role in it but
each person has to discover for
themselves what's unleashes and what
brings down the walls of literally
seeing the water around you and for me
it's it's as a robot I listen to music
quite a bit because I think something
about music and the complexity of sounds
allows my brain to to to see new things
so to speak
question about the impact that your
company is I don't know what how I made
it on the list so let me just start off
with with that so I think technology
represents a huge opportunity for for
Africa so the way I think about the
opportunities with technologists
especially in Africa is I think at some
point I don't know if it's 10 20 years
from now the all the phones in the world
will probably be smartphones right so
you have you know the poor African armed
with with a smart phone right and that
for the first time allows them to access
and allow the canal creates an ecosystem
a marketplace for people to build the
kinds of apps and services are actually
create value for them you know the large
corporations and most of the governments
in in in Africa have done a poor job and
really catering to the to the to the
average man so once you have these
phones in the hands of you know the
average African you can now allow them
to access a whole variety of resources
and assets that they they never had an
opportunity to so in healthcare in
education I mean financial services all
those or things that make a big impact
on the lives of the everyday African so
we we don't invest specifically as
saying we're gonna invest poorly in
Africa my my my vision and for the
comfort of venture builder I'm based out
of New York City that I'm working on is
to be able to address global
opportunities there was including those
here in Africa
in comparison to current before the two
other incubators or accelerators that
out there what are you gonna do
differently from the one that you see
right now yeah well that's the secret
sauce that I'm working on and and
there's so many elements to it and I
really can't discuss in detail but you
know so so but there's the short answer
to the question is there in my mind
there there are basically four things
you need to have a successful companies
in the initial years right so you have a
great idea you have a wall functioning
team you probably have a product that
has some traction and you have capital
right you know people could disagree in
a few things but I think roughly those
are the elements of this early stage
success and and I believe that that each
of those processes right currently each
of them is broken right so just think
about how people think about team
building a team right so you guys are I
think mostly it's very very technical I
Harry school at Stanford but you know
the typical process you know so like
let's take the case of Harvard right so
a Harvard Business School student says I
have a great idea let me go to MIT let
me figure out a technical co-founder
right which may make sense but you have
limited resources you need to figure out
the best persons who will help you work
on the idea but I think what you'll find
like the probably the number one reason
why internet companies fill in the early
days is is kind of internal team
dynamics right so it's it seems odd to
me that a an industry focused on
disrupting and innovating other peoples
industries right that this is all we
have right this kind of kind of LOC
based approach and this kind of highly
networks approach was finding team like
what are the characteristics so a person
like me with a certain attributes of
what I think are important in my own
life and my own work style isn't there a
more far away to think about team team
building right like it is do we is this
really the the optimal set of process
and sort of you know building a team so
I think there's lots of things that can
be done around it you know product
cycles for example this another one
right so you have these entrepreneurs
obviously lean lean startups as a major
theme right but I feel like even within
that industry right so if you go to an
incubator and accelerator and they have
speakers tell you about best ways to
think about your MVP there's still so
much that you have to learn right and oh
there's so much wasted in that effort of
you to figure out how do I go from an
idea to you know prototype to an MVP etc
same thing with capsule raising right so
and you guys are here in the heart of
Silicon Valley so you probably have an
easier chance of meeting and those
having those kinds of meetings that
allow you to raise venture capital but
for the most for most other parts of the
world right people don't have that
opportunity and I think there's a much
smarter way of really aligned in capital
to these kinds of ideas so those are
essentially those three things I'm I'm
trying to build systems around you know
people products and then I'm capsule
so I grew up in a dress I mentioned and
I came here when I was 16 years old and
what's something that really affected me
is this whole idea of the power of
business to change lives right because
you know I always believed that and
everyone knows is like the African
countries in general are not very people
friendly you know they're the one
resource that human beings have you know
about one you know our own selves right
people kind of downplay for natural
resources and others as well
so what I found was just the power of
business to change lives so that was a
big factor in the way I think about what
is valuable work right so I definitely
think business is right up there with
education with being a doctor etc
because you solve problems and my
definition of of entrepreneurship is
solving problems profitably right with
limited resources right so that's how I
think what I really think of every every
startup donor every oh I intend to do is
geared toward solving a real problem for
people so that's the way I think about
but there's but but on your question
there's one is one experience I had that
actually realized was actually much more
important than I've actually thought
about which is the whole so I the for
one of the first real job I had was as
an intern that is coming called AG way
it's now it's now bankrupt right but
that was an inter and but and the whole
idea was I had to basically they had all
these reporting units and I had to plan
use Excel I had to use a database and I
had to use Excel to basically to
streamline the reports in for for all
their different operating units and
coming to think about it right that
experience allowed me to have a certain
comforts with information and how to
think about data that that then allowed
me to kind of be able to attack the
hopsital problem right so you'd be
surprised how those out those nuggets of
experiences are now become the thing
that gives you a leg up or gives you
insight into the nature of different
different problems
you talk about finding the right people
it's a hard thing and whether it's
people you're looking to help you build
out your next platform or less before
you're looking to invest in what are two
or three the qualities or
characteristics that you have developed
in sentence a little for people that you
align yourself here so I think but I
mean people already discussed this yeah
so I'll try to figure out how to spin it
differently so I you know they talk
about skillsets right and keep the build
so I know my I think I've been able to
have a look at myself and figure out
well these are the things I'm good at
and things that I'm not good at and the
logical step for me is to figure out
people who can do the things that I
don't want to do or can't do so I think
that's just the first one but I think
there's no there's no one way to do it
like the CEO of Hopstop who did a great
job running a company him an are
entirely different right he went through
a basically a whole transitioning of
people at the company just because him
and I have different kind of work styles
and personalities so there I don't think
there's a particular answer some people
could be very analytical but but slow
and there's people who are and kind of
guts driven right and and quick and so
it's you know really you can really
there's no real kind of one answer for
for that kind of question but the things
that matter of is their kind of interest
in passion in the products that you want
to build and your ability to really be
able to work with them right which is
such a key then again that the team
dynamics is one of those over under
looked or overlooked parts of
entrepreneurship but I think people
should really really think about it
before before consist on the journey I
was reading I think Apple but hop stuff
around
someone out there what what what all you
think waiting for that process to deal
having them actually purchase it through
without a mouthing what were they really
looking at I know where the the billion
dollar can because it was certainly not
not public and I've never said what the
what the and Apple hasn't either said
whether what the purchase price was I
just want to be clear on that
so the the obviously rationale is what I
initially explained they needed again I
don't know what the rationale is I mean
let me be clear on that but I I assume
it's because of the relevance of
transits into the core Apple American
products but again it's something that
happened and and happy it did but it's
not something that I like that that
drives kind of the decisions I make it
generally
you